I think I'm a pretty good judge of character and I love sharing tips and tricks with people which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficiently. This episode is supported by WriteUp and they're a brand I've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years. I really do genuinely rate them and use the Write Up platform for each and every clinic session I book or conduct. That's why I'm so happy to be working with them. In case you don't know already, Write Up isn't all in one practice. management platform built in the UK for UK clinicians. So that's your diary, your client records, your notes, your invoicing, your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant,
我认为自己是一个相当不错的性格鉴赏家，我喜欢与人们分享技巧和诀窍，这些技巧和诀窍确实能帮助他们更高效地经营临床诊所。本期节目由 WriteUp 赞助，这是我在自己的临床诊所里已经使用了六年多的一个品牌。我是真心实意地推崇他们，并在我预订或开展的每一次诊所会诊中都使用 Write Up 平台。这就是为什么我这么高兴能与他们合作。如果你还不知道的话，Write Up 并不是一个大杂烩式的诊所管理平台，它是专门为英国临床医生在英国打造的。所以，从你的日程、客户记录、病历、开票到安全消息，所有这一切都在一个地方，全部符合 GDPR 合规要求，
all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in, they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap to pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you, hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with a system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P dot com. And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users.
全部都是围绕着我们实际的诊疗方式来设计的。另外，最新消息是，他们最近推出了一个能为你起草会诊记录的 AI 速记员，以及一个能把你的智能手机变成读卡器的碰触支付应用。这两者都是那种能悄悄地为你每周省下好几个小时的小改变。不过，如果你不想使用所有这些功能也没关系，你完全可以不用。如果你一直打算整理你的行政工作，或者你正苦于应付一个根本不是为你量身打造的系统，那就去看看 writeup.com 吧。也就是 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P 点 com。当你使用我的优惠码 Marianne 30 时，你可以获得一个免费的 30 天试用期，最多可供 6 个用户使用，并且享受六个月内七折的优惠。
What's not to like. Now on with the show. Why do some fears disappear whilst others seem to live in the body and the mind forever? Why can one bad experience shape someone for years? And why do humans keep expecting the worst even when things are actually okay? Today Dr Martin Quigley and I unpack the fascinating psychology behind extinction learning, phobia's anxiety, habits and how our brains learn safety. And if you've ever been ghosted, stick around to find out what that's all about too.
这还有什么挑剔的呢。现在言归正传。为什么有些恐惧会消失，而有些恐惧似乎永远留在身心之中？为什么一次糟糕的经历就能塑造一个人多年？为什么人类总是在事情其实还好的时候却一直在期待最糟糕的情况发生？今天，马丁·奎格利博士和我一起探讨了消退学习、恐惧症、焦虑、习惯以及我们的大脑如何学习安全感背后的迷人心理学。如果你曾被人“人间蒸发”过，请留下来听听这到底是怎么回事。
Hope you find it really useful. Welcome along to psychology. Actually, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. And today I'm joined by Dr. Martin Quigley. Welcome along, Martin. Hello, good morning, everybody. Thank you so much for being here.
希望你会觉得这真的很有用。欢迎来到《实际上是心理学》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起做客的是马丁·奎格利博士。欢迎你，马丁。大家好，早上好。非常感谢你能来到这里。
Could you tell us, in a nutshell, what your job is and what you do? Certainly. So I'm a senior lecturer in the School of Psychology at Swansea University. I've worked there for the last six or seven years now. And my day-to-day job involves teaching and researching all things related to psychology. I primarily teach on undergraduate programs at the moment, teaching things like research methods and statistics, introduction to clinical psychology, individual differences, which involves things like personality, intelligence, and learning, psychopathology. conditioning and gambling harm. So wide variety of different topics there and I also
你能简单概括一下你的工作是什么以及你是做什么的吗？当然可以。我是斯旺西大学心理学学院的高级讲师。我在那里工作了大概有六年或七年了。我的日常工作包括教学以及研究所有与心理学相关的事物。目前我主要教授本科生课程，教的内容包括研究方法与统计、临床心理学导论、个体差异（这涉及性格、智力和学习等方面）、心理病理学、条件反射以及赌博危害。所以那里有各种各样不同的主题，我也
research in all those areas as well. Very wide variety and it's bringing back lovely memories of some of my undergrad content. So yeah, thank you for that. So we're getting together today to think about something called extinction learning. Could you help us understand kind of what that is? Certainly. So I guess there's two parts to understanding this concept, which is a really basic and fundamental aspect of psychology. If we think about the term learning, we may often think about classroom contacts with young children, being taught in school environments, or we may be thinking about people acquiring a certain skill, something like they may be
在所有这些领域进行研究。主题非常广泛，这勾起了我很多本科学习内容的美好回忆。所以，是的，谢谢你。因此，我们今天聚在一起，思考一个叫做“消退学习”的概念。你能帮我们理解一下那到底是什么吗？当然可以。所以我想理解这个概念有两个部分，这是心理学中一个非常基础和根本的方面。如果我们想到“学习”这个词，我们通常可能会想到与幼儿的课堂接触，在学校环境中接受教育，或者我们可能会想到人们获得某种技能，比如他们可能在
learning to swim in later life or learning a musical instrument or language. When we're talking about learning in psychological terms, what we're talking about is a relatively permanent change in behaviour based on some experience that you've had. So that's the phenomena that we're referring to when we're talking about learning within psychology. When we're talking about extinction learning, we are referring here to this process of reducing a learned response to something or replacing an association that's being formed there. And it's a really powerful concept that we experience all the time in our day-to-day lives. and I'll give a few examples that I often refer to my students to help them try and understand this,
晚年学习游泳、或是学习一件乐器或是一门语言。当我们在心理学意义上谈论学习时，我们所谈论的是基于你所经历的某种体验而产生的相对持久的行为改变。因此，这就是我们在心理学中谈论学习时所指的现象。当我们谈论“消退学习”时，我们指的是这样一种过程：减少对某事物的习得反应，或者替换在那里形成的某种联结。这是一个非常强大的概念，我们在日常生活中无时无刻不在体验着它，我将给出一些我经常向学生提及的例子，来帮助他们试着理解这一点，
which usually resonate quite well with a relatively young population. I'll often refer to something like a WhatsApp conversation, where two individuals may have gone out, they may have met, they may have gone on a date, and one of them sends a message to the other, and the others perhaps hasn't been sort of feeling this date, and they produce no response. They ignore it, right? I'm sure everybody's had that response,
这些例子通常能在一个相对年轻的群体中引起很好的共鸣。我经常会提到类似 WhatsApp 对话这样的例子，其中两个人可能出去过，他们见过面，可能约会过，然后其中一个人给另一个人发了一条消息，而另一个人可能并没有那种约会的感觉，于是他们没有做出任何回应。他们无视了它，对吧？我确信每个人都有过那种经历，
whether it's on a date or a friend or a colleague. And what happens is the individual who sort of prompted this communication, may send them another message, and they don't get a response again. That is effectively extinction, right? There's no outcome. There's no response there. And what you're doing is you're effectively training the individual
无论是约会对象、朋友还是同事。结果就是，那个促成这次沟通的人可能会再发一条消息，而他们依然没有得到回应。这实际上就是消退，对吧？没有结果。那里没有回应。而你正在做的事情，实际上就是在训练这个人
to stop sending you messages, right? If you don't want someone to email, tell you if you stop responding, that's a very effective example of extinction learning. That's a very sort of simple example in our day-to-day life, but it obviously can expand a lot of different scenarios. And I think we're going to talk a little bit today about some clinical examples as well where that could be relevant. Oh, Martin, that's really made me cackle. Oh, my eyes feel all watery. Like what we've done is we've got a psychological term for ghosts. That's what happens when someone ghost you.
停止给你发消息，对吧？如果你不想让某人给你发邮件，如果你停止回复，那就是消退学习的一个非常有效的例子。这只是我们日常生活中一个非常简单的例子，但它显然可以扩展到许多不同的场景中。我想我们今天也会讨论一些相关的临床例子。哦，马丁，这真的让我咯咯笑了。哦，我的眼睛都湿润了。就像我们做的那样，我们给“人间蒸发”起了一个心理学名词。当有人对你“人间蒸发”时，发生的就是这个。
That's precisely right. Yeah. It's extinction learning. I have to say whenever I was dating, I wasn't a ghoster, but I did used to go on date sometimes and maybe tell someone to their face. Yeah, this is great. We should definitely do this again if they asked. And then get home and be like, sorry, I just wasn't feeling it
完全正确。是的。这就是消退学习。我必须承认，每当我约会时，我虽然不会玩“人间蒸发”，但我有时确实会去约会，如果对方问起的话，我可能会当面告诉某人：“是的，这很棒。我们绝对应该再约一次。”然后回到家就会觉得：“抱歉，我只是没有那种感觉”，
because it is uncomfortable, but I would always reply. But yeah, when someone's ghosting you, I guess there can be a variety of reasons, but, you know, training someone to not bother me again, again is a very lovely idea. I think my husband would quite like to think about extinction learning for me when it comes to the corner of the work surface in the kitchen where I tend to open my post and maybe leave it and then the whole table where we come in where I will put my bottles and anything I happen to be carrying at the time when I come through the door. How can we how can we begin to change habits that maybe annoy us a little bit as well, but annoy other people?
因为这让人感到不舒服，但我总是会回复。但是，是的，当有人对你“人间蒸发”时，我想原因可能有很多，但是，你知道的，训练某人不再来烦我，这又是一个非常美妙的想法。我想我丈夫可能会很乐意为我考虑一下关于消退学习的问题，就拿厨房里我倾向于打开信件并可能随手放在那里的那个工作台角落来说，还有我们进门时的整个桌子，我会在穿过前门时把水瓶和手里拿着的任何东西随手放在那里。我们怎么才能开始改变那些可能让我们自己有点烦恼、但同时也惹恼别人的习惯呢？
Can we use Extinction Learning for that? Yeah, so the key premise behind Extinction Learning, if we think about it as like breaking an association that already exists, right? It's the removal of an outcome. It's the removal of some form of reinforcement. month. So as I indicated there that in the, I like your, yeah, it's effectively ghosting, right, where you're not providing a response there. It could be that you have a, you can apply this to any organism, right, to children, to animals. It could be that you have a child who's seeking attention and they know if they go to a certain area of the room where they're not supposed to go,
我们能把消退学习用在这上面吗？是的，所以消退学习背后的核心前提，如果我们把它看作是打破一个已经存在的联结的话，对吧？它就是结果的移除。它就是某种形式的强化物的移除。正如我刚才所指出的，在……我喜欢你的……是的，这实际上就是“人间蒸发”，对吧，你没有提供任何回应。这可能是你有一个……你可以把这个应用于任何有机体，对吧，应用于儿童、动物。可能你有一个寻求关注的孩子，他们知道如果他们走到房间里某个不被允许去的区域，
that you're going to respond, right? You're going to stand up. You're going to go over. You're going to guard the area. If you keep on doing that, you're going to, you're going to are effectively reinforcing that behaviour. If you remove the response, obviously you have to do this in a safe environment, you can't let them sort of wander off into danger. But if you remove that response, that is extinction. And all organisms are effectively good at realising this change in their environment, this change in behaviour and the change in contingencies there. So that simple removal of a response, a reinforcer and outcome is incredibly effective. And I would argue we see that all the time in the environment around us. And it's just understanding where extinction's happening and how it can be
你就会做出回应，对吧？你会站起来。你会走过去。你会把守那个区域。如果你一直这样做，你就会……你实际上是在强化那种行为。如果你移除了这个反应，显然你必须在一个安全的环境中这样做，你不能让他们不知不觉走到危险的地方。但是如果你移除了那个回应，这就是消退。而所有的有机体实际上都很擅长意识到环境中这种改变、行为的改变以及权变关系的改变。因此，简单地移除一个回应、一个强化物、一个结果是极其有效的。我认为我们在周围的环境中经常看到这一点。这只是去理解消退发生在何处以及它如何能够
used powerfully and how it can really influence our own behaviour. I'm acutely aware of how I'm using extinction in my day-to-day life, not just as a researcher, but as an individual who's thinking, right, do I want to reinforce this? Do I want to encourage this? Do I want to prompt a response? Yeah. Those sorts of questions are ever present on my mind. Yeah, I wonder if you can kind of apply this extinction learning to sibling birth order and how parenting changes as well, because that definitely made me think about when I had just one child, if he'd been crawling over to the curtains and, you know, jangling them and, you know, wobbling them. I'm not, no, darling, we don't do that.
被有力地使用，以及它如何真正地影响我们自己的行为。我敏锐地意识到我在日常生活中是如何使用消退的，不仅作为一个研究人员，而且作为这样一个个体，我在想：“对，我想强化这个吗？我想鼓励这个吗？我想促成一个回应吗？”是的。诸如此类的问题时刻萦绕在我的脑海中。是的，我想知道你是否可以把这种消退学习应用到同胞出生顺序以及育儿方式的改变上，因为这确实让我想起当我只有一个孩子的时候，如果他爬向窗帘，你知道的，拉扯它们，晃动它们，我会说：“不，不，亲爱的，我们不能那样做。”
You know, I'd been redirecting and giving him attention. Second time around, probably so tired, and just wanted a break, I'd probably have a little bit of an assessment and be like, hmm, it's fine. Not going to kill himself, he's just playing in the curtains. So have I extinguished my own response there? Is that what I've done? Possibly.
你知道的，我会转移他的注意力并给他关注。第二次当父母时，可能太累了，只是想休息一下，我大概会稍微评估一下，然后觉得：“嗯，没关系。他不会摔死的，他只是在窗帘里玩。”所以，我是在那里消退了我自己的回应吗？这就是我所做的吗？有可能。
There's also another related to, we like lots of technical terms within our learning theory and conditioning, which is my sort of area of expertise and where I did my PhD. There's possibly other explanations which sound very similar. and on the surface they are, they're quite subtle in their difference, which is habituation. And habituation sounds technical, but it's simply the fact that repeated exposures to something have a sort of a diminishing effect on our behaviour. So a classic example, and again, these are things that I'm certainly aware of all the time around me. You may have had experience of living
这还涉及到另一个概念，我们在学习理论和条件反射中喜欢很多专业术语，这是我擅长的领域，也是我攻读博士学位的地方。可能还有其他听起来非常相似的解释。表面上看确实如此，它们的细微差别相当微妙，那就是习惯化。习惯化听起来很专业，但它其实很简单，即反复接触某事物对我们的行为有一种逐渐减弱的影响。一个经典的例子，再次强调，这些是我周围时刻注意到的事情。你可能曾有过这样的经历：住在
in a flat or an environment where there's a noisy neighbour in the first couple of days, you know, you're really startled by this. You can hear every foot. step and you're almost like heightened arousal as a response to it and then a couple of weeks or months later you just start to drown that out right that just become you habituate to it is the technical term it's that reduced response um that's occurring uh in your environment and i think of that often when i've had friends for instance when i lived in a flat where i did have noisy neighbors above me who would come and stay over with me and they'd be really like what's going on up there and i'd be like oh yeah that's that's my neighbour. You know, that's just how loud they are. But to them, it's really startling.
公寓或某个环境中，头几天有吵闹的邻居，你知道的，你真的会被这吓到。你能听到每一个脚步声，作为回应，你的觉醒状态几乎处于高度亢奋，然后几周或几个月后，你开始把那种声音淹没掉，对吧？那只是变成……专业术语叫做你习惯了它。就是那种减少了的反应……发生在你的环境中。每当我有朋友来访时我常常会想起这一点，例如，当我住在一个公寓里时，楼上确实有吵闹的邻居，他们会来跟我一起住，他们会觉得：“天哪，上面在搞什么？”而我会说：“哦，是的，那是我的邻居。”你知道的，这就是他们的声音有多大。但对他们来说，这真的很吓人。
To me, living there for months on end, I've just habituated to that. And that's possibly what's also happening there when you were talking about that response when you're like, they're okay. Yeah, that's happened before. There's no negative. You just, you're sort of adapting to that. Yeah, that makes total sense. And that really reminded me, you know, if you go into someone's house and they live quite near a train line and you hear a, Oh, and you're like, oh, wow, train. I didn't even hear it. And you're like, wow, because they've habituated to that and they've stopped hearing it.
对我来说，在那里住了好几个月后，我已经习惯了。当你谈到那种反应时，可能也是这种情况发生时的状态，当时你会想：“他们没事。是的，这以前发生过。没有什么负面的。”你只是……你有点适应了。是的，这完全说得通。这真的让我想起，如果你走进某人的房子，他们住在靠近铁路线的地方，你听到一声“哦”，然后你会说：“哦，哇，火车。我甚至都没听到。”然后你会说：“哇”，因为他们已经习惯了那个声音并且不再去听它了。
It makes me think of an old neighbor I used to have. And we lived in a terraced row. And one of the neighbors got a husky dog who used to like to howl a lot. And the walls were quite thin because it was a new build. I just couldn't habituate to that. And one of the reasons that we kind of wanted to. move ultimately. So there's some things that we can habituate to and others that are always going to be trickier, I would guess. Yeah. Yeah, there's massive individual differences. So I would
这让我想起了我以前的一个邻居。我们住在联排别墅里。其中一个邻居养了一只哈士奇，它喜欢经常嚎叫。因为是新建的房子，墙壁相当薄。我就是无法习惯那个声音。这也是我们最终想要搬家的原因之一。所以我想，有些事情我们可以习惯，而另一些事情则总是会更棘手。是的。是的，存在着巨大的个体差异。所以我会
argue extinction as a phenomena, habituation the same is generally applicable to organisms, to animals and humans, but everybody has different thresholds, right? So like people's sensitivity to extinction learning or to habituate into things. things is going to vary. Not everybody's going to have the same response. And people are going to have different, what's salient to someone, so what stands out in their environment is going to be different to people. Some people may be particularly sensitive to an auditory sound. So it may be the sound of the train or the dog, whatever it may be, whereas some people say, that doesn't bother me, but there's a little red light in the corner,
认为消退作为一种现象，习惯化也是如此，通常适用于有机体、动物和人类，但每个人都有不同的阈值，对吧？因此，就像人们对消退学习或习惯化事物的敏感度一样，每个人都是不同的。并不是每个人都会有相同的反应。人们会有不同的……对某人来说显著的东西，也就是他们在环境中脱颖而出的东西，对其他人来说是不同的。有些人可能对听觉声音特别敏感。所以可能是火车或狗的声音，无论它可能是什么，而有些人会说：“那不困扰我，但角落里的那个小红灯”，
which is really irritating me. You know, well, I've certainly been this person myself, with suddenly, for some reason, the ticking of a clock becomes like the lounder. loudest sound in the world and I've literally had to take the batteries out of the clock. Now, you know, I've heard that ticking of a clock a long time, but for whatever reason at that particular moment in time, that becomes particularly salient to me. So everybody has different thresholds there. Oh, it's making me realise my thresholds where everything are quite low. I've definitely been in Airbnb's and I had to take clocks off walls and move them. And then if my husband's charging a toothbrush and it's flashing, I'm like, I can see it. He's like, you've got an eye
真的在激怒我。你知道的，嗯，我自己肯定也当过这种人，突然之间，由于某种原因，时钟的滴答声变得像世界上最响亮的声音，我不得不把时钟里的电池拿出来。现在，你知道的，我听时钟滴答声已经很久了，但无论出于什么原因，在那个特定的时间点，它对我变得格外显眼。所以每个人都有不同的阈值。哦，这让我意识到我各种阈值都挺低的。我绝对住过那种不得不把墙上的时钟拿下来并移开的民宿。然后如果我丈夫在给牙刷充电而且它在闪烁，我会说：“我能看到它。”他说：“你闭上眼睛”，
I can still see it. So yeah, maybe I need to work on my tolerance. So if he was wanting me to not put things on the hall table, part of my argument is that's what a table is for. But we could maybe use some pattern interruption to get me to think more before I do that. Would that be kind of like an errorless learning type thing? Or is that a completely different concept that I've just one in there, Martin. Yeah. Yeah, there are two different things. This is, um, airless learning and extinction learning. So in errorless learning, we're trying to introduce some form of sort of mastery and guidance and a prompt, which could be very effective for the reason that you're saying. If, if, if this was someone, it's typically used in populations, perhaps in rehabilitation for people who
“我还是能看到它。”所以，是的，也许我需要提升一下我的容忍度。因此，如果他希望我不要把东西放在门厅的桌子上，我的部分论点是桌子本来就是用来放东西的。但我们也许可以使用某种模式中断来让我在做那件事之前多思考一下。那会类似于无错学习那种类型的东西吗？还是说这完全是一个不同的概念，我刚才只是把它们混为一谈了，马丁？是的。是的，这是两码事。这是……无错学习和消退学习。所以在无错学习中，我们试图引入某种形式的精通感、指导以及提示，这对于你所说的原因可能会非常有效。如果……如果这是一个人的话，它通常被应用于某些群体，也许是在针对某些人的康复治疗中。
who've had some neuropsychiatric issue. So in that particular instance, it would be trying to, what whilst the skill of all the behaviours being learned, is trying to prevent any errors from creeping in. So that one, they sort of gain an efficient mastery of the skill quickly without any potential interference. Two, from like an efficiency perspective of sometimes when people do learn errors or even if it's unnecessary behaviors, it may not be that they're doing something wrong, but it's just inefficient.
有神经精神方面问题的人。因此，在那种特定的情况下，它将试图在学习所有行为的技能的同时，尽量防止任何错误潜入。这样一来，一方面，他们可以不用任何潜在的干扰就能快速有效地掌握技能；另一方面，从效率的角度来看，有时当人们学习错误，甚至是不必要的行为时，可能并不是他们在做错事，而只是效率低下。
It's not a necessary thing to do. That can cognitively be a competing demand, which can place sort of an additional stress. And if you're thinking about populations, perhaps, where they may not have the capacity for that. If they've had some issue like a stroke or they have some sort of behavioral issues where they're particularly sensitive to things,
这不是一件必须要做的事。这在认知上可能会产生一种竞争性需求，从而带来某种额外的压力。如果你考虑到某些人群，也许他们在这方面可能没有足够的承受能力。如果他们遇到过中风之类的问题，或者他们有一些对某些事物特别敏感的行为问题，
it's a sort of a fast and efficient way to doing that. Extinction learning is different in the sense that is purely focusing on almost how to break or an association that's been formed or sort of reduce a response there. But there are certainly other behavioral phenomena that could be applied or behavioral techniques to reduce that behavior that you've referred to there if you were leaving something where your husband didn't want you to. So that's where perhaps
这是一种快速且有效的方法。消退学习则不同，它纯粹关注的是如何打破已经形成的联结，或者说减少那里的反应。但是，肯定还有其他可以应用的心理学现象或行为技术来减少你所提到的那种行为，比如当你把东西落在你丈夫不希望你放的地方时。所以，这就是
things like reinforcement would be particularly relevant or things like positive punishment, negative punishment, that those techniques could be more applicable there. So it could be the case that, you know, if he wanted you to do that, perhaps he provides you with some reinforcement, positive reinforcement by giving some sort of reward or incentive or if he wanted that to stop he could try and sort of introduce some what these sound like very technical terms here when we're thinking about this in behavioral terminology but it could be that there's some sort of aversive outcome to that that if you do that the you know the meal doesn't get cooked tonight or whatever that may be right which sounds very autocratic there but that that's sort of like the basic terminology that is used
诸如强化之类的东西会特别相关，或者诸如正惩罚、负惩罚之类的技术在那种情况下可能会更适用。因此，可能的情况是，你知道，如果他希望你这样做，也许他会为你提供一些强化，通过给予某种奖励或激励来进行正强化；或者如果他希望这种行为停止，他可以尝试引入一些——当我们用行为术语来思考时，这些听起来像是非常专业的术语——但可能会有一些厌恶性的结果，如果你那样做了，今晚就没有饭吃了，或者诸如此类的事情，对吧？这听起来可能有点专断，但这正是用来
to try and sort of explain how we can reinforce or remove people's behaviours. I see. So it's those power games, isn't it? If you keep leaving your water bottle there, I'm going to put it in the bin, and then you'll learn because you won't have a water bottle. But what I would prefer, now I'm speaking to you, is like, well, every day that I don't leave anything on the hall table, how about I have a five-minute massage? Because that will be my reward. And then over time, I won't need the reward. So is that like a little bit of a little bit of, bit of, I can't remember the order. Is it operant conditioning? Classical conditioning? What would it be? Would it be classical if I didn't need the reward anymore? Yeah. Yeah. Well, so operant conditioning is
试图解释我们如何强化或消除人们行为的基本术语。我明白了。所以这就是那些权力游戏，对吧？如果你一直把水杯留在那里，我就把它扔进垃圾桶，然后你就会吸取教训，因为你将没有水杯了。但我更希望的是——现在我和你说话——比如，我不在门厅桌子上留任何东西的每一天，我可不可以享受一个五分钟的按摩？因为这将是我的奖励。随着时间的推移，我将不再需要这个奖励。那么，这有点像、有点像、有点像——我记不清顺序了。这是操作性条件反射？经典条件反射？这会是什么？如果我不再需要奖励，会是经典条件反射吗？对。对。好吧，所以操作性条件反射是
what you're going to do, where there's some form of reinforcement. Classical conditioning is a simple pairing of events. So that's when two events appear together regardless of your behaviour. So for instance, the classic example is which also psychology seems we'll be familiar with is from Ivan Pavlov, a Russian physiologist who won a Nobel Prize for his work. And in that particular instance, he was looking at the salivation responses of canines, dogs to food. And what he noted is that whenever there was an auditory cues, who commonly is referred to as a bell or it could be a metronome, which signal that the food would be delivered, the dog started to salivate in response to it. So they had learned an association that there's an auditory cue, there's a sound in my
你要做的事情，其中包含某种形式的强化。经典条件反射则是事件的简单配对。也就是当两个事件一起出现时，无论你的行为如何。例如，最经典的例子——所有心理学专业的人都会熟悉——来自伊万·巴普洛夫，一位因其研究而获得诺贝尔奖的俄罗斯生理学家。在那个特定的例子中，他研究了犬类（狗）对食物的唾液分泌反应。他注意到，每当有听觉线索（通常被称为铃声，也可以是节拍器）预示着食物即将来临，狗就会开始流分泌唾液作为回应。因此，他们学会了一种联结，即有一个听觉线索，我
environment that predicts the delivery of food. And that wasn't contingent on anything they did. That was going to happen anyway, but they started to salivate as soon as they heard the sound, right? That's classical conditioning, two events which appeared together. Operant conditioning is where there's some consequence as a result of your behaviour. So that would be, if we were to try and take that example I've just provided there with Power Plov and the dogs, that would be that the food would only be rewarded if they did something, right? So perhaps they were trained to sit on command or to raise their paw and sort of high-five the experiment, whatever it may be, that would sort of be a form of operant conditioning.
环境中的声音预示着食物的递送。这并不取决于他们做了什么。这无论如何都会发生，但他们一听到声音就开始流口水，对吧？这就是经典条件反射，两个一起出现的事件。操作性条件反射则是指作为你行为的结果而产生某种后果。因此，如果我们试着采用我刚才提供的巴普洛夫和狗的例子，那将意味着只有在它们做了某些事情时，食物才会作为奖励发放，对吧？所以也许它们被训练成听口令坐下，或者抬起爪子与实验人员击掌，无论那可能是什么，这在某种程度上就是一种操作性条件反射。
So going back to your example there, which you raised, if you didn't want something left in a certain area of the house, for instance. and you said you kind of like the idea of positive reinforcement. That would be, and it doesn't need to be tangible, right? Not all of these things, like the degree of positive reinforcement that is provided is, you know, that's dependent upon the individual and the resources they have available. It could simply be praise. It could be, thank you so much for doing that. It really helped.
所以回到你刚才提出的例子，如果你不希望某样东西留在屋里的某个特定区域，比如你曾说过你挺喜欢正强化这个主意。那将会是——而且它不需要是触手可及的东西，对吧？并不是所有这些东西，比如提供的正化程度，你知道的，这取决于个人以及他们手头可用的资源。它可能只是简单的赞美。它可能类似于：“非常感谢你这么做。这真的很有帮助。”
I didn't have the need to speed around and clean things up from that area today. It really helped me able to get to work earlier, which meant that I could get back early and we could spend more time together. Whatever that may be, it doesn't. Or it could be, you know, thank you for doing that. I want to pick something up for you as a little treat on the way back. What would you like, right? And that could be the process.
“我今天不需要急急忙忙地去清理那个区域的东西了。这真的帮我能更早去上班，这意味着我可以早点回家，我们可以花更多的时间在一起。”无论那可能是什么，它不需要。或者可能是，“谢谢你这么做。在回来的路上我想为你买点小零食作为犒劳。你想要什么？”对，这可以是一个过程。
I love that idea. I'm all about the praise, all about the positive. So yeah, it could just be when you spot something that hasn't happened that usually would, that you'll actually thank you. I noticed that the whole table was clear today. And I really loved it because it helped me do a bit of a deep. exhale and like, oh, okay, good. I'm not having to moan about that today. Yeah, I think I can definitely think about, yeah, like praising and reinforcing some stuff around my parenting as well,
我喜欢这个主意。我完全支持赞美，完全支持积极的方面。所以，是的，可能就是当你发现某件通常不会发生的事情没有发生时，你实际上会说谢谢。我注意到今天门厅的桌子是干净的。我真的很喜欢，因为它帮我大大地舒了一口气，感觉“哦，好吧，太好了，我今天不用为此唠叨了”。是的，我觉得我绝对可以考虑，比如在我的育儿过程中也加入赞美和强化一些事情，
because it can be so easy to trip into just moaning at people, can't it? And we forget to say thank you or forget to notice the absence of certain behaviours or the presence or of other more pro-social behaviours. I'd argue as well that it's something that I've sort of become acutely aware of is, and I think most people I spoke to agree to us, when a job's done well often, we sort of, there's little praise in in many instances because we go, well, that worked as it should. And when something doesn't go right, we're very sort of alert to that. Like you can teach 400 people a year and 399 can be like, that's great, I enjoyed that.
因为人们很容易陷入只会对别人唠叨的境地，不是吗？我们忘记说谢谢，或者忘记注意到某些行为的缺失，亦或是其他更多亲社会行为的出现。我也想说，这是我开始深刻意识到的一点，而且我想我交谈过的大多数人都会同意这一点：当一件工作做得很好时，通常情况下，很多时候很少有赞美，因为我们会觉得“嗯，这本该如此”。而当事情进展不顺利时，我们就会非常警觉。比如你可以一年教400名学生，其中399名可能会觉得“太棒了，我很喜欢”。
And you may hear from one or two of those 399 people who said, Thank you. That was really useful. I learned a lot. Now, there may be one person who hated it for whatever reason. They didn't like the style. They didn't like the delivery. They didn't get what they thought they were going to get. And you can guarantee you'll be hearing from them, right, to say, I'm not happy with this process. And so I always try and think of, I like to provide that positive reinforcement to the things that I see. So if I sort of have a pleasant meal and a lovely, you know, the service around that, I'll say thank you. I really enjoyed that. That was a lovely meal and I appreciate that.
而你可能会从那399人中的一两个人那里听到：“谢谢。这真的很有用。我学到了很多。”现在，可能有一个人无论出于什么原因讨厌它。他们不喜欢这种风格，不喜欢这种授课方式，没有得到他们原以为会得到的东西。我向你保证，你一定会听到他们的声音，对吧？他们会说“我对这个过程很不满意”。所以我总是试着去想，我喜欢对我看到的事情提供积极的强化。因此，如果我吃了一顿愉快的饭菜，体验了可爱的服务，我会说谢谢。我真的很喜欢。那是一顿可爱的饭菜，我很感激。
If I go to a bank and I have to talk to someone and they help me and it's not, you have to ring this call line and come back in 14 days and fill out seven forms. I'll say, thank you. That was really efficient. I appreciate that. Is there any positive feedback I can provide? So I'm very much someone who seeks to provide that positive reinforcement in the world around me to try and sort of encourage the things that I think are doing well.
如果我去银行不得不和某人交谈，他们帮助了我，而且不是那种“你必须拨打这个客服热线并在14天后回来填七张表”的情况。我会说谢谢。这真的很有效率。我很感激。有什么我可以提供的积极反馈吗？所以我非常倾向于在我周围的世界中提供那种正强化，以试图鼓励那些我认为做得很好的事情。
And then likewise, if things aren't, you know, of course you got to feed that back appropriately. But I think there's often a skew towards when things work well, that's what should have happened. When things didn't, that's where people become sort of alert and potentially a bit more vocal about things. Absolutely. And of course, as humans, we've got this negative attribution by us, haven't we? And that's there to save our life, really, because it makes sense to pay attention to the stuff that is maybe a risk or, you know, is kind of a bit erroneous than what we're expecting. but that doesn't always lead to us having, you know, a sedate, calm, happy experience. I love the idea of actually, yeah, praise it.
同样的，如果事情没有做好，当然你必须适当地给予反馈。但我认为通常存在一种偏见：当事情进展顺利时，人们会觉得那是理所当然的；而当事情搞砸时，人们才会变得警惕起来，并可能对事情发表更多意见。绝对的。当然，作为人类，我们有一种消极偏差，对吧？这其实是为了拯救我们的生命，因为关注那些可能构成风险的、或者有点出乎我们意料的错误事物是合乎情理的，但这并不总是能让我们拥有平静、安详、快乐的体验。我真的很喜欢“去赞美它”这个主意。
I do that as well. Makes me think of when I was in Prett-M-J in Bath. And I met the loveliest, loveliest woman there who worked there. And I have to say, I use Pratt a lot, but I don't use it for their cheery, you know, banter. I generally find it's quite officious, you know. there's not much two-way repartee. This lady was lovely. She deserves an award. And so I thanked her. I told her that she'd been my favourite pre-staff ever. And then I sent something into head office as well because it matters, doesn't it? It really does matter. You know, when we're doing
我也这么做。这让我想起我在巴斯的Pret-A-Manger的时候。我在那里遇到了一个最可爱、最可爱的女员工。我必须说，我经常光顾Pret，但我去那里可不是为了他们那欢快的玩笑。我通常发现它相当官僚，你知道的，没有什么双向的互动。这位女士非常可爱。她应该获得一个奖。所以我向她表达了谢意。我告诉她她是我遇到过的最喜欢的Pret员工。然后我还给总部发了反馈，因为这很重要，不是吗？这真的很重要。你知道的，当我们做得
something well, that should be recognised as well. 100%. And it's those little things which can have a huge impact. And it can not that this is the intention for doing this, but it can be sort of reciprocally beneficial. I've certainly done that with people where I've been impressed and sort of raise the fact that I would like to provide some positive feedback to staff, line managers, whoever it may be. And then indirectly, that's come around to sort of benefit myself where someone will reach out to me on LinkedIn and say, thank you so much for that. I didn't realize you did that. That was so helpful. If there's anything I can ever do for you. And then you've sort of got a connection there. And it's not done in that sort of cynical way. It's just trying to encourage the things that
很好的时候，那也应该得到认可。百分之百。正是那些小事情会产生巨大的影响。而且——并不是说这就是这样做的目的——它可能具有互惠互利的性质。我当然对那些给我留下深刻印象的人做过这种事，并提出我希望向员工、直线经理或任何相关人员提供一些积极的反馈。然后间接地，这反过来又让我自己受益，有人会在领英（LinkedIn）上联系我，说“非常感谢你那样做。我没意识到你做了这些。那太有帮助了。如果有什么我能为你做的”。然后你在那里建立了一种联系。这不是以那种愤世嫉俗的方式做的，它只是试图鼓励你周围
being done well around you, but I think it can also sort of come back in a positive light sometimes as well, where that has a nice feel for both of you, where you get sort of a friend or a connection out of that as well. So that may also be applicable to people with certain autistic traits or behaviours as well. Yeah. And that said, if people want to offer us any positive feedback for this episode, we would love to hear it. You can tag us both on socials. Dr. Martin Quigley is on LinkedIn. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. I genuinely love it. When people tag me in their stories, they say, I'm listening to this. I really love it. Sharing it with their audience. And also on LinkedIn, you can leave someone a recommendation, can't you. If you really value them, you've worked with them, you've worked under them, you've worked above them, you've worked alongside them and you want to endorse them, you can do that. So people don't always know that about LinkedIn. Okay, so before we hit record, I was telling you that when I was in sixth form, people used to chase me around with horrible, scratchy sponge.
做得好的事情，但我认为有时它也能以一种积极的姿态回报你，让你和对方都感觉很好，你也能从中结交朋友或建立联系。所以这也可能适用于有某些自闭症特征或行为的人。是的。话虽如此，如果人们想为这一集提供任何积极的反馈，我们非常乐意听到。你可以在社交媒体上同时标记我们。马丁·奎格利博士（Dr. Martin Quigley）在领英上。我是到处都是的玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。我真的非常喜欢。当人们在他们的快拍中标记我，说“我在听这个，我真的很喜欢”，并与他们的受众分享时。同样在领英上，你也可以给别人留下推荐，不是吗？如果你真的很珍视他们，你和他们共事过，你曾在他们手下工作过，你曾在他们之上工作过，你曾与他们并肩作战，并且你想背书他们，你可以做到这一点。所以人们并不总是知道领英的这个功能。好吧，所以在我们按下录音键之前，我曾告诉你，当我读预科时，人们过去常常拿着可怕的、粗糙的海绵追着我跑，
because I'm not a fan of sponges. But obviously when it comes to phobias, that is a fairly low level and it doesn't really impact on my life. But phobias can really ruin people's lives, can't they? And I understand that extinction learning can help with that. Yeah. So, yeah, just to provide some context to what we mean when we refer to a phobia, because often people ask me, do I have a phobia? Or is this a phobia? I don't like this thing.
因为我不是海绵的粉丝。但显然，当谈到恐惧症时，那只是一个相当低的水平，它并没有真正影响我的生活。但恐惧症真的会毁了人们的生活，不是吗？我明白消退学习可以对此有所帮助。是的。所以，为了给我们所说的“恐惧症”提供一些背景信息，因为人们经常问我：我有恐惧症吗？或者这是一个恐惧症吗？我不喜欢这个东西。
What is the sort of definitional criteria? So the most common clinical definition of the phobia is an irrational fear of an objectively harmless stimulus or situation. So by irrational here, we mean something which isn't quite logical given the information that we know. So if somebody has a fear of heights, but they're in an incredibly dangerous situation where they could fall, we would say, well, that is a logical, rational fear, right? They're in a dangerous situation. But if they're an entirely safe situation, there have been any instances or accidents and they
什么是定义标准？因此，临床上对恐惧症最常见的定义是：对客观上无害的刺激或情境产生不合理的恐惧。这里的“不合理”，我们指的是鉴于我们所知道的信息，它并不是很符合逻辑。如果某人对高度感到恐惧，但他们正处于一个随时可能坠落的极度危险境地，我们会说，嗯，这是一种合乎逻辑的、理性的恐惧，对吧？他们处于危险境地。但如果他们处于一个完全安全的情境中，没有任何事件或事故，而且他们
have no fear, but they have a fear of heights, we may say that this is irrational, an irrational fear. And simple or specific phobias are very common. So these are phobias of things. So it could be spiders, snakes, or situations, things like heights, being on a plane. And they are very, very, very common type of anxiety disorders. So a phobia is classed as an anxiety disorder and they're very popular in most populations. Estimates typically range them between about 7 to 15% of the population may experience a simple or specific phobia in their lifetime. And the sort of predominant view of how, or certainly one of them, as to how phobia's form is through this process of learning and conditioning. So the classic example, which is referred to within pretty much all psychology
没有恐惧，但他们有恐高症，我们可能会说这是不合理的恐惧。简单或特定恐惧症非常普遍。所以这些是对具体事物的恐惧。可能是蜘蛛、蛇，或是某些情境，比如高度、坐飞机。它们是非常、非常、非常常见的一类焦虑症。因此，恐惧症被归类为焦虑症，它们在大多数人群中非常普遍。估计值通常在7%到15%的人口之间，他们一生中可能会经历简单或特定恐惧症。而关于恐惧症如何形成的主流观点之一，是通过这种学习和条件反射的过程。
textbooks is referred to as Little Albert or Baby Albert. And this was a study conducted by two researchers over 100 years ago now in 1920 by researchers Watson and Rainer. And in this particular example, what they claim to have demonstrated is how they could, in essence, condition someone to have a phobia. So to teach someone a phobia, which is obviously something which is highly ethical to do, but this was a quite a long time ago when a lot of these studies took place. And in their famous example, what they did was they showed a young baby named Albert, who was approximately one years old, a white rat. And whilst the white rat was being presented, they created a loud noise behind the baby's head. So they struck two metal bars together. And that
几乎所有心理学教科书中提到的经典例子都被称为“小阿尔伯特”（Little Albert）或“小婴儿阿尔伯特”。这是两位研究人员在100多年前的1920年进行的一项研究，研究人员是沃森（Watson）和雷纳（Rayner）。在这个特定的例子中，他们声称已经证明了他们如何能本质上通过条件反射让某人产生恐惧症。也就是教导某人产生恐惧症，这在道德上显然是一件极具争议的做法，但这是在很久以前进行的，当时许多此类研究都在那个时期开展。在他们著名的例子中，他们做的是向一个大约一岁的小男孩阿尔伯特展示了一只小白鼠。当小白鼠出现时，他们在婴儿的头部后面制造了一个巨大的噪音。所以他们敲击了两根金属棒，而这
was evidence of a conditioned fear being respond, being conditioned there. So this would happen. repeatedly, so over a number of different trials, and this would essentially result in an association be informed that when this rat is present, there's a really unpleasant or aversive thing that happens, a loud noise which couldn't be explained. That research has been a sort of foundation for lots of the models and theories that have developed since in order to try and treat phobias and provide effective therapeutic interventions, and extinction learning is absolutely critical to that. trying to be achieved in extinction learning is to remove or replace that association that's been formed, that the rat suddenly symbolizes something which is aversive in the environment.
就是条件恐惧反应正在被形成的证据。这种情况会重复发生，即在多次不同的试验中发生，这本质上将导致形成一种联结：当这只老鼠出现时，就会发生一件非常令人不快或厌恶的事情，即一个无法解释的巨大噪音。这项研究已经成为自此以后为了治疗恐惧症和提供有效治疗干预而发展起来的许多模型和理论的基础，而消退学习对此至关重要。消退学习试图实现的目标是移除或替换已经形成的联结，即老鼠突然象征着环境中某种令人厌恶的东西。
And for the large part of the history of the field, there was almost an assumption that extinction learning could erase or effectively delete that association. And what extinction learning would involve in this particular context would be presenting the, um, the, the feared object or in this case, animal, which would be a rat, and ensuring that there was no negative or aversive outcome. So there'd be no loud noise or nothing upsetting, which happens. And the idea in extinction learning is, if you present the person with this feared thing over and over again,
在该领域历史的很大一部分时间里，几乎有一种假设认为消退学习可以抹去或有效地删除这种联结。在这个特定语境下，消退学习所涉及的内容是呈现那个被恐惧的对象，或者在本案中是动物——即老鼠，并确保没有出现消负面或厌恶的结果。也就是说，不会有巨大的噪音或任何令人不安的事情发生。消退学习的理念是，如果你一遍又一遍地向这个人呈现这个令人恐惧的事物，
with no aversive outcome being delivered, this would effectively, the idea was historically that this would effectively sort of remove that association or rub it out. But we know that's not the case now. And this is something that is well established within the empirical literature. We know that extinction is not an erasure of that association. It's not the removal of that association. And we know that thanks to a few different types of studies that have been conducted
且没有产生任何厌恶的结果，这实际上——历史上的观点是——将有效地消除这种联结或将其抹去。但我们现在知道事实并非如此。这是实证文献中已经充分确立的一点。我们知道消退并不是对这种联结的擦除。它不是这种联结的移除。多亏了所进行的几种不同类型的研究，我们才得以了解这一点。
and a few different types of phenomena that's been reported. One of those is simply referred to a spontaneous recovery. So another technical term, but it's a very simple process. And what that simply means is if you condition someone through extinction learning to expect that now when they're presented with the thing that they feared the rat, that no negative outcome will appear, you can see effective extinction. So the organism may start to be very calm and they may not to show that fear. However, you may try and test that again in hours, days, weeks, months later and suddenly that fear response reemergence. And that's a particular concern for us because we want people to not relapse. We want people to not fall back into these patterns and to learn to show these associations that they've previously.
以及已经报道过的一些不同类型的现象。其中之一简称为自发恢复。所以这也是一个专业术语，但过程非常简单。它的意思很简单，如果你通过消退学习对某人进行条件反射，让他们预期现在当他们面对他们害怕的东西——那只老鼠时，不会出现任何负面结果，你就能看到有效的消退。因此，有机体可能会开始变得非常平静，并且可能不会表现出那种恐惧。然而，你可能会在几小时、几天、几周、几个月后再次尝试测试，突然间那种恐惧反应又重新出现了。这让我们特别担忧，因为我们希望人们不要复发。我们希望人们不要落入这些模式中，并且学会表现出他们之前没有的那些联系。
So the question of interest for us there is what's actually happening? Why is that happening? What is Extinction learning doing what we originally thought, which was sort of erasing that association? And the answer is that it is not erasing the association. what instead is happening, and we know this thanks to brilliant academics like Professor Mark Boughton, who's done lots of work on this and developed lots of theories, has demonstrated that what is effectively happening is a new type of learning, referred to as inhibitory learning, where they're learning that the outcome does not happen,
所以我们对此感兴趣的问题是，实际发生了什么？为什么会这样？消退学习是在做我们最初认为的事情，也就是某种程度上抹去那种关联吗？答案是，它并没有抹去这种关联。相反发生的情况是——多亏了像马克·博顿（Mark Boughton）教授这样杰出的学者，他在这个领域做了大量工作并发展了许多理论——他已经证明，实际上发生的是一种新型的学习，被称为抑制性学习，即他们在某些情况下了解到结果并不会发生，
the thing that they're expecting, in certain circumstances. And what we think is happening there is that it's dependent upon the context that they find themselves in. And the factors that influence whether or not what is a context can be a source of debate there. But I think I can give a really nice example, which highlights this. Let's place this in a clinician's office.
也就是他们所预期的那件事情不会发生。我们认为在那里发生的事情是，它取决于他们所处的环境。而影响什么可以被视为环境的因素可能会引发一些争论。但我想我可以举一个非常好的例子来突出这一点。让我们把它放在一个临床医生的办公室里。
Let's imagine we have an individual who has had some traumatic experience with the dog. And maybe that they themselves were bit or attacked by a dog where they witnessed a loved one or friend or family member be attacked by a dog. Now, they have this association that the dog is dangerous and that the dog can be a source of anxiety for them. A clinician may be successfully able to reduce their fear to the dog by gradually exposing them to dogs in safe environments such as the clinician's office. And they may therefore learn, okay, I do not need to be afraid of dogs when I'm in the clinician's office.
让我们想象有这样一个人，他曾有被狗咬伤的创伤经历。也许他们自己被狗咬过或攻击过，或者他们亲眼目睹了所爱之人、朋友或家庭成员被狗攻击。现在，他们有了这样一种联系，即狗是危险的，狗会成为他们焦虑的来源。临床医生可能能够通过在安全环境（如临床医生的办公室）中逐渐让他们接触狗，成功地降低他们对狗的恐惧。因此他们可能会了解到，好吧，当我在临床医生的办公室里时，我不需要害怕狗。
The problem is what happens when they leave the clinician's office. that's where the fear may reemerge. And here we can see a perfect example. This is referred to as context renewal of what Mark Bouten's research has demonstrated, that the original association has not been erased or removed. It's still there. It's just been replaced or we've tried to replace it
问题是，当他们离开临床医生的办公室后会发生什么。恐惧可能就在那时重新出现。在这里我们可以看到一个完美的例子。这被称为环境更新，它展示了马克·博顿的研究已经证明的内容：最初的关联并没有被抹去或移除。它依然存在。它只是被替换了，或者我们试图替换它，
and written over it with a new set of associations, which is a form of inhibitory learning. The problem is when they leave that environment, that old association is still there. It's still sort of dormant in the mind. So when they go to a new environment, they now may walk back from the clinician's office through the park and be very apprehensive of the dogs. What they've effectively learnt is not dogs do not equal danger. What they've learned is dogs do not equal danger in the clinician's office. So the task of the clinician and the researcher is to try and find ways to generalize to make that new form of learning
并用一组新的关联将其覆盖，这是一种抑制性学习的形式。问题在于，当他们离开那个环境时，那个旧的关联依然存在。它在脑海中仍然处于某种休眠状态。因此，当他们去到一个新的环境时，他们现在可能会从临床医生的办公室穿过公园走回去，并且对狗感到非常忧虑。他们实际上学到的并不是“狗不等于危险”。他们学到的是“狗在临床医生的办公室里不等于危险”。因此，临床医生和研究人员的任务就是寻找方法来进行泛化，使这种新形式的学习
as applicable as possible to lots of different environments. And there's been lots of work which has been done now to try and examine ways in which we can do that most effectively. Really fascinating stuff. But of course, you can only really work with someone on a phobia if they want to have a change, if they want that to be different. So my husband is not a fan of spiders. And many a time I have said, come on, you know, we'll get rid of it.
尽可能适用于许多不同的环境。现在已经做了大量的工作，试图检验我们能以何种最有效的方式做到这一点。这真的是迷人的东西。但是，当然，只有当一个人想要改变，想要有所不同时，你才能真正与他们一起处理恐惧症。所以我的丈夫并不是蜘蛛的粉丝。我有很多次都说过：“得了吧，你知道的，我们会把它弄走的。”
Like, we'll do some work, we'll do this. Nope, not interested. And I guess I would want to think with you about, you know, I don't love the idea of flooding to help people to overcome phobias. And I would love your thoughts on kind of treatment for phobias, Martin. That's a great point. Yeah, you're 100% right. You can't treat someone if they don't want to receive the treatment.
比如，我们会做一些工作，我们会做这个。不，不感兴趣。我想和你想一想，你知道的，我不太喜欢用满布疗法（flooding）来帮助人们克服恐惧症。马丁，我很想听听你对恐惧症治疗的看法。这真是个好问题。是的，你百分之百正确。如果一个人不想接受治疗，你是无法治疗他们的。
And it's particularly awkward. Exposure therapy is generally considered to be the most effective intervention for phobias. It's probably one of the best treatments we have for certain conditions. The issue, like you say, is with exposure therapy, you have to go and realize that effectively you are going to end up having to be exposed to the thing that you're afraid of. There's no two ways around it, right? So you have to be willing to accept that. Flooding is a sort of extreme form of exposure where the individual is confronted with the thing that they're afraid of immediately and rapidly.
而且这特别尴尬。暴露疗法通常被认为是治疗恐惧症最有效的干预手段。它可能是我们针对某些病症拥有的最好的治疗方法之一。正如你所说，问题在于使用暴露疗法时，你必须去意识到，实际上你最终将不得不暴露在你所害怕的事物面前。这没有什么别的出路，对吧？所以你必须愿意接受这一点。满布疗法是一种极端的暴露形式，患者会立即且迅速地面对自己害怕的东西。
So that could be, for instance, that someone who's afraid of snakes, so phobia, phytophobia, would literally be presented with a snake, which would obviously be very stressful for them. And there are ethical issues around that as well in terms of how do they respond? What type of response does that produce in them? They may have a panic attack. They may have some sort of physical unpleasant response to that, which you need to be concerned about. So flooding is not widely used.
因此，举例来说，一个害怕蛇的人（即蛇类恐惧症患者）会字面意义上面对一条蛇，这显然会给他们带来巨大的压力。而且在这方面也存在伦理问题，就他们的反应而言？这会在他们身上产生什么类型的反应？他们可能会惊恐发作。他们可能会对此产生某种身体上的不适反应，这是你需要关心的。因此，满布疗法并没有被广泛使用。
What is typically employed in sort of the most robust empirical evidence points towards a form of therapy referred to a systematic desensitization. And this is a form of therapy where the individual has very gradual exposure to the thing that they're afraid of over weeks or months. And they will effectively establish what is referred to as a hierarchy of fear. So it may be that they simply start off with saying they don't like the name of the thing that they're afraid of. So often people say, I don't even like the word spider or tranchler. That just sounds so unpleasant to me, right? So the first stage would literally be getting them to talk about what that is, why that is, and getting them used to the term. So maybe just getting used to seeing the term written down, getting used to saying the term.
最稳健的实证证据通常倾向于采用一种被称为系统脱敏疗法的治疗形式。这是一种治疗形式，其中个体在几周或几个月的时间里，对他们害怕的事物进行非常渐进的接触。他们将有效地建立所谓的恐惧等级。所以可能是他们首先从说出他们害怕的事物的名字开始，他们就是不喜欢它。人们经常说：“我甚至不喜欢‘蜘蛛’或‘塔兰图拉毒蛛’这个词。这听所以第一阶段字面意义上就是让他们谈论那是什么，为什么会这样，并让他们习惯这个术语。所以也许只是习惯看到这个词被写下来，习惯说出这个词。
That would literally be stage one of the process, right, with a training. clinician who's going to talk about that with them. The next step may be looking at a picture. It may be looking at a cartoon picture, right? It may be something which is a bit more comical and then starting to sort of gradually get used to seeing pictures of real spiders or watching videos. Then it could be watching someone interact with a spider, but doing so from a safe environment. Then it could be being in the same room or watching one through a glass tank. And then that process can gradually build up all the way to where, of course, they will have to want to do this, but where they may be able to hold one within their hand. And that would be an incredibly successful outcome if they can do that and remain calm and feel comfortable with that.
这字面意义上就是这个过程的第一阶段，对吧，在一位会与他们讨论这一问题的专业临床医生的指导下。下一步可能是看一张图片。可能是看一张卡通图片，对吧？可能是更滑稽一点的东西，然后开始逐渐习惯看真实蜘蛛的图片或观看视频。然后可以是看着别人与蜘蛛互动，但要在安全的环境中这样做。然后可以是在同一个房间里，或者透过玻璃箱观察。然后这个过程可以逐渐升级，直到他们当然必须自己愿意这样做，但他们可能会能够在手里拿着一只。如果他们能够做到这一点，并且保持冷静并对此感到舒适，那将是一个令人难以置信的成功结果。
The question of interest that clinicians and researchers are interested in is how long can we maintain that behavior? Is there a relapse issue? I mean, lots of studies will look at things like post-test follow-up. So if they come back and check whether they're still comfortable six months time, a year's time, two years time, ten years time, like how permanent is that behavior? And that's what we're most interested in. Like I say, the empirical evidence is pretty strong. There is obviously relapse issues there, which are going to occur. But we do have a pretty good base to build on with the scientific evidence about things like systematic desensitization.
临床医生和研究人员感兴趣的问题是，我们能够将这种行为维持多久？是否存在复发问题？我的意思是，很多研究会关注诸如测试后随访之类的事情。所以如果他们回来检查六个月后、一年后、两年后、十年后他们是否仍然感到舒适——这种行为有多持久？这正是我们最感兴趣的。就像我说的，实证证据相当强有力。显然那里会有复发问题发生。但关于系统脱敏疗法等事情，我们确实有相当不错的科学证据作为基础。
And just very quickly, we talked about this very briefly. at the start of it. There's now new approaches to rolling out some of these therapies as well, which involve technology like virtual reality headsets. So it can be difficult to get access to certain things that people are afraid of, and it can be difficult to create controlled environments where they're safe. But there are some packages where people will have access to an app. I've worked with a brilliant team, Emmercify, who are based at Swansea University, to develop one for arachnophobia, where the participant or the patient
非常简短地说，我们在开始时非常简短地讨论过这一点。现在也有推出其中一些疗法的新方法，它们涉及虚拟现实（VR）头显等技术。因此，要接触到人们害怕的某些事物可能会很困难，要创造他们感到安全的受控环境也很困难。但有一些软件包可以让人们访问一个应用程序。我曾与一个杰出的团队合作——Emmercify，他们总部位于斯旺西大学——为蜘蛛恐惧症开发了一个应用程序，其中参与者或患者
would have a virtual reality headset on. And within this environment, they'd first be exposed to the thing that we're afraid of. Say it was a spider on the table. Then they could walk up to the table. Then they could remove the thing in the particular app that we created the final stage was that they could actually pick it up with a cup
将戴上虚拟现实头显。在这个环境中，他们首先会接触到我们害怕的东西。假设桌子上有一只蜘蛛。然后他们可以走到桌子前。然后他们可以移除我们创建的特定应用程序中的那个东西，最后阶段是他们实际上可以用杯子把它捡起来，
and using the handset or to hit it with a paper, which was resting unstable. So there's all sorts of cool new technologies which can allow interesting ways to interact with some of those things in a scalable way, which doesn't require that sort of one-to-one of a patient going through everything in a room together. Yeah, really good. It does sound like fascinating stuff and it's kind of making me remember kind of shark phobia. And obviously, for the most part, if you don't live near the sea or you don't regularly go in the sea, that's probably not so much of an issue. But actually sometimes people are so scared of sharks. I mean, my kids were watching Jaws this morning. I came downstairs and they were watching Jaws like, oh, nothing like
并使用手柄，或者用一张放在桌上不动的纸把它拍掉。所以有各种各样很酷的新技术，可以以可扩展的方式与其中一些东西进行有趣的互动，而不需要那种患者和医生共处一室、事事进行面对面的模式。是的，真的很好。这听让我想起了鲨鱼恐惧症。显然，在大多数情况下，如果你不住在海边，或者你不经常下海，这可能不是太大的问题。但实际上有时人们非常害怕鲨鱼。我的意思是，我的孩子们今天早上在看《大白鲨》。我下楼时，他们正在看《大白鲨》，心想：没有什么比
watching Jaws at 6.30 in the morning. So I don't think they have shark phobia. But some people will really struggle to sit on a sofa and have their feet on the floor because it makes them feel vulnerable and it's that shark feeling. And similarly, sharks do crop up everywhere, don't they? They might be on greetings cards or you know you might suddenly see one on a poster or a train station or you know you might be on a on a tube and there might be now someone's reading the National Geographic and there's a picture of a shark so even things that you think are not actually super common in people's lives if it is impacting on them clinically impacting on their sleep reducing their well-being that is to something they might want to engage with so that they
在早上6点30分看《大白鲨》更美妙的了。所以我不认为他们有鲨鱼恐惧症。但有些人真的很难坐在沙发上把脚放在地板上，因为这会让他们感到脆弱，这就是那种鲨鱼带来的感觉。同样地，鲨鱼确实随处可见，不是吗？它们可能会出现在贺卡上，或者你可能突然在海报上、火车站看到一只，或者你可能在地铁上，现在可能有人在读《国家地理》，上面有一张鲨鱼的照片。所以即使是你认为在人们生活中并不超级常见的事情，如果它在临床上对他们产生影响，影响他们的睡眠，降低他们的幸福感，那这也是他们可能会想要去处理的事情，这样他们
can just feel calmer and happier and less, you know, more in control, less disturbed. And I guess the VR would work really well for that because we don't generally get up and close and personal with sharks. There's actually a study on that precise, with shark phobias. And there's only one that I'm aware of. I'm sure there may be more. But there's one where, and it was a very small sample. I'm not even sure if it was a case study. So it was one participant who took part in it. But where they developed a program which precisely addressed that where they could literally see the shark then you know be in that environment there's there's always that difficulty and we were talking about that in terms of that balance of like irrational and rational fears because obviously things like sharks
就能感到更平静、更快乐，减少（你知道的）更多的控制感，减少困扰。我想VR对这一点非常管用，因为我们通常不会与鲨鱼近距离接触。实际上有一项关于这个精确主题的研究，针对的是鲨鱼恐惧症。据我所知只有一个。我确信可能还有更多。但有一个研究，样本非常小。我甚至不确定它是否是一个案例研究。所以只有一个参与者参与其中。但他们在那里开发了一个程序，精确地解决了这个问题，在那里他们可以字面意义上看到鲨鱼，然后（你知道的）置身于那个环境中。总会有这种困难，我们当时在讨论这种不理智和理智恐惧之间的平衡，因为显然像鲨鱼这样的东西
are can be dangerous things like spites can be dangerous it's just proportionally how much of an impact and how much danger are they having on your day to day life and the answer is probably very slim. But if you're living a life where you are sort of constantly aware and alert and conscious and its impact in your day-to-day activities, that is a problem. If you're somebody who enters a room and you're wondering where the spiders may be and there's no sign of any spider and you've not seen a spider and it's not spider, you know, that's probably having an impact on your life. if you're somebody who's worried about going to an outing in case they've got some sort of, you know, zoo where it's going to be a spider or something like that,
可能是危险的，像蜘蛛这样的东西可能是危险的，关键在于它们对你的日常生活产生了多大比例的影响和危险，而答案可能非常微小。但如果你过的生活是那种你某种程度上不断保持警惕、注意和清醒，并且它影响了你的日常生活活动，这就是个问题。如果你是一个进入房间就会想蜘蛛可能在哪里，而没有任何蜘蛛的迹象，你也没有看到蜘蛛，它也不是蜘蛛（你知道的），这可能正在影响你的生活。如果你是一个担心去郊游的人，万一那里有什么（你知道的）动物园，里面会有蜘蛛或类似的东西，
and you don't want to walk around it and you're thinking, I may not want to go out to that. That's impacting on your life. If you're not sleeping well because you're worried that there may be a spy behind the headboard, that's exactly what you said. That's causing psychological distress. That's disrupting your sleep, your well-being, your ability to socialize with people. So it has like wide range in impact, even with things that like you say may not appear obvious to people.
而你不想绕着它走，并且你心想：我可能不想去那次郊游。这正在影响你的生活。如果你因为担心床头板后面可能有一只蜘蛛而睡不好觉，那就是你刚才所说的那样。这正在引起心理痛苦。这正在扰乱你的睡眠、你的幸福感、你与人交往的能力。所以它具有广泛的影响，即使对于那些像你所说的那样对人们来说可能并不明显的事情也是如此。
Spider-snakes heights are typically the three most common, but it's not unique to those things. People have focus or all sorts of things like you've addressed. Amazing. That's fascinating stuff. And thinking then about the kind of positive feedback and positive appraisal, is there any way we might be doing ourselves a disservice when we maybe haven't been worried about things and then we just, you know, brush it off at a later days. Yeah, so there's a key theory which is developed by Michelle Crask, who's in states in UCLA, I believe, and she's done some work looking at how extinction learning can be sort of generalized more broadly. So if we think that things aren't being erased or things aren't being deleted
蜘蛛、蛇、高度通常是最常见的三个，但并不局限于这些东西。人们对各种各样的事情都有恐惧，正如你所提到的。太棒了。这真是引人入胜的内容。那么接下来思考积极的反馈和积极的评估，有没有可能当我们之前没有为某些事情担心，然后我们只是（你知道的）在稍后的日子里把它刷掉时，我们实际上是在帮倒忙？是的，这里有一个由米歇尔·克拉斯克（Michelle Crask）提出的关键理论，据我所知她在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA），她做了一些研究，探讨如何将消退学习更广泛地泛化。因此，如果我们认为事物没有被抹去，或者事物没有被删除，
and says, how can we make sure that that generalise, as much as possible. And one way to do this is to reflect on instances where we may, the technical term is experience expectancy violation. So we expect something bad to happen. We may be worried about some outcome. We may have some fear, but it doesn't happen. Now, the key there is to actually reflect on the fact that, okay, the adverse thing that I thought was going to happen didn't happen. What we may often do is simply sort of write that off and go, okay, well, today went well, but God knows what's going to happen tomorrow, right? And it's about reflecting on that expectancy.
并且说：我们如何确保这种泛化尽可能广泛？做到这一点的一个方法是反思我们可能（用专业术语来说）经历预期违背的实例。我们预期会发生不好的事情。我们可能会担心某种结果。我们可能会有一些恐惧，但它并没有发生。现在，这里的关键实际上是反思这样一个事实：好吧，我以为会发生的负面事情并没有发生。我们经常做的事情可能只是把它一笔勾销，然后说：好吧，今天过得很好，但鬼知道明天会发生什么，对吧？这就是关于反思那种预期。
Like, well, you thought that was going to be a bad thing yesterday. And nothing happened. It all went well. That concern that you had about that awkward meeting with that colleague, it didn't happen. That concern that you had that, whether it's in a clinical context, that the dog was going to bark, the spider was going to bite, that didn't happen. So it's trying to reflect on those instances and really recognize them to try and update. the information that we have there and to get a more realistic assessment of things to some extent that, okay, things are okay, they're not always going to work out negatively for me.
就像：嗯，你昨天以为那会是一件坏事。结果什么都没发生。一切都进展顺利。你对与那位同事尴尬会面的担忧，并没有发生。你所担心的那些事——无论是临床背景下狗会叫、蜘蛛会咬——都没有发生。所以这是试图反思那些实例并真正认识到它们，以更新
I can have some, you know, positivity of this and realize the reality of what's going on. So I think that's really important and that's been identified as one of the strategies, which was really effective in treating phobias, that realization that the bad thing that I thought was going to happen didn't happen and really sort of, you know, recognizing that point. Sounds that we can use this as a strategy for retraining people who have, shall we say, as a glass is half empty approach, you know, every time they put a letter in a postbox, they're like, it's going to get lost because it always gets lost.
我们那里拥有的信息，并在某种程度上对事情做出更现实的评估：好吧，事情还好，它们并不总是会对我产生负面的结果。我可以从中获得一些（你知道的）积极性，并认识到正在发生的事情的现实。所以我认为这真的很重要，这被确定为治疗恐惧症非常有效的策略之一，那种意识到我以为会发生的坏事并没有发生，并且真正去（你知道的）认识到这一点的意识。听起来我们可以把这当作一种策略，用来重新训练那些可以说是“悲观主义者”的人，你知道的，每次他们把一封信投进邮箱时，他们都觉得：这会弄丢的，因为它总是弄丢。
It's like actually, well, when that letter arrives, we need to notice that and we need to kind of retrain and re-experience that because we can't just pay attention to the awful stuff. If that doesn't happen, we should we should celebrate. celebrate that and notice it. Yeah. It's like you say about that positive praise point, which we mentioned earlier, it's recognising when things go right
这就好像实际上，嗯，当那封信到达时，我们需要注意到这一点，我们需要重新训练并重新体验这一点，因为我们不能只关注糟糕的事情。如果那没有发生，我们应该庆祝。庆祝这一点并注意到它。是的。就像你刚才提到的关于积极表扬的那一点，我们之前提到过，它是指当事情顺利时能够认识到这一点，
and accepting that and realizing that, well, often it's when we focus on the things that go wrong or the bad things or the adverse of things that happen, but recognising when things go right, like you may have a fear of a lift and you may have got in a lift and it's not worked. You may have got in a lift 99 other times and it's worked all of those times, right?
并接受这一点，并意识到，嗯，通常当我们专注于出错的事情、坏事或发生的逆境时，却忽视了当事情顺利时的状态——比如你可能对电梯有恐惧，而你坐过电梯，它没有故障。你可能在其他99次里坐过电梯，每一次它都正常运作，对吧？
So it's like recognizing that. My good friend Kara wouldn't let me finish this episode without me sharing with our audience about the time that I did the most psychologist type complaint ever. So it was when we were all aspiring psychologists and we'd all gone out probably as a group of about 20 assistant psychologists when we were working at St Andrews in Northampton. And I'd ordered the mushroom risotto and I am a risotto fan. I can cook it, I like it, and I will regularly choose it on menus. And afterwards, it hadn't been nice. I think I'd asked for some extra salt or some other stuff. And then at the end of the meal, I asked if I could see someone from the kitchen team.
所以这就像是认识到这一点。我的好朋友卡拉（Kara）不会让我完成这一集，除非我与我们的听众分享我做过的最具心理学家风格的抱怨的那一次。那是当我们都还是有抱负的心理学家时，我们在北安普顿的圣安德鲁斯工作时，可能作为大约20名助理心理学家的群体一起出去了。我点了一份蘑菇意面（risotto），我是意面的粉丝。我会做，我喜欢它，我经常在菜单上选择它。之后，它并不好吃。我想我要了一些额外的盐或其他东西。然后用餐结束时，我问我是否能见一下厨房团队的人。
And I said, I'll just want to give you a little bit of feedback on the risotto. I really think that you could benefit from reformulating the rest of it. be. My friend Kara still howls with laughter that I suggested the word reformulation, which of course is at the essence of psychology, isn't it? A lovely constructive wording as well there. I hope they appreciated that. That was probably one of the more sort of generous comments that they received in it as a form of a complaint. I think so. Very measured. Very measured. Very measured indeed. Dr. Martin Cruegley, it's been an absolute pleasure to speak with you.
我说：“我只是想对这个意面给出一小点反馈。我真的认为你可以从中受益，重新配方剩下的部分。”我的朋友卡拉仍然在大声嘲笑我竟然建议使用“重新配方”（reformulation）这个词，这当然是心理学的精髓，不是吗？那里也是一个可爱且具有建设性的措辞。我希望他们能欣赏这一点。作为一种抱怨的形式，这可能是他们收到的比较慷慨的评论之一。我想是的。非常克制。非常克制。确实非常克制。马丁·克鲁格利博士，与你交谈绝对是一种荣幸。
I could have spoken to you all day, every day. If there's future episodes, people might find helpful, kind of speaking with you about, you know, one idea I've got is whether kind of having a little look at kind of undergrad psychology curriculum and what someone might learn and how that might show up in our everyday lives, because I think it's said that basically everything we do in psychology is kind of an expansion of a theory we learn in those early stages. of A level and undergrad. But yeah, if anyone's got any ideas or things they'd like us to expand on,
我本可以跟你聊上一整天，每天都聊。如果有未来的节目，人们可能会觉得有帮助的话，和我谈谈（你知道的）我有一个想法，就是看一看本科心理学课程，看看某人可能会学到什么，以及这如何表现我们的日常生活中，因为我认为据说我们在心理学中所做的一切本质上都是我们在A-Level和本科早期阶段学到的理论的扩展。但是，是的，如果任何人有任何想法或希望我们展开的话题，
please do let us know in the comments or ask us a question, reach out to us on social media. Where can people learn more about you and your work, Martin? So, yeah, thank you. If you simply Google Martin Quigley, I'm usually the first result. My university page is there. My LinkedIn will come up my Google Scholar profile, which will have all my research on my personal website as well, I update that with all of my research, my teaching activities, any news that I'm, any talks I'm
请务必在评论中告诉我们或向我们提问，在社交媒体上联系我们。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你的工作的信息，马丁？所以，是的，谢谢。如果你简单地谷歌搜索“马丁·奎格利（Martin Quigley）”，我通常是第一个结果。我的大学网页在那里。我的LinkedIn会出现，我的谷歌学术个人资料也会出现，上面有我的所有研究，还有我的个人网站，我会用我的所有研究、我的教学活动、我正在进行的任何演讲来更新它。
giving anywhere. So yeah, I should be. I'm lucky. I think the spelling of my name with a Welsh spelling of Martin with the Y and the Quigley is relatively unique. So I'm first up on the Google search trends there. Perfect. An early adopter for the Martin Quigley with a Y, love it. Thank you again for your time. I think this is a really lovely episode. Excellent. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for your time in watching. If you're not already a subscriber, then why not? Do it now, follow the show.
无论在哪里进行。所以，是的，我应该会的。我很幸运。我认为我的名字的拼写带有威尔士风格的马丁（Martin），带有一个“y”，而奎格利（Quigley）相对独特。所以我排在谷歌搜索趋势的第一位。太完美了。一个带“y”的马丁·奎格利的早期采用者，太棒了。再次感谢你的时间。我认为这是一集非常棒的节目。太棒了，非常感谢。非常感谢你收看。如果你还不是订阅者，那为什么不呢？现在就行动，关注这个节目。
And if you're watching on YouTube and you click the little bell button, you'll be notified as soon as I release new content. If you're striving for a career in psychology yourself, I think you'll really find the aspiring psychologist membership helpful, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. If you find this content helpful, I would love to know. Do drop me a comment wherever you. you're watching or listening. And if all this talk of research has wet your appetite
如果你正在YouTube上观看，并且点击了那个小铃铛按钮，一旦我发布新内容，你就会收到通知。如果你自己正在为心理学职业生涯而奋斗，我想你会发现“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”真的很有帮助，你只需每月30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限要求。如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，我很想知道。请在无论你在哪里观看或收听的地方给我留下评论。如果所有这些关于研究的讨论都勾起了你的胃口，
and made you think that you should potentially apply for research roles, then I think you'll really like the video that's on screen now that you can watch if you're on YouTube. And I will link in the show notes as well. And that episode was with the lovely Jess. I think I'm a pretty good judge of character
让你觉得你可能应该申请研究职位，那么我想你真的会喜欢现在屏幕上的视频，如果你在YouTube上，你可以观看它。我也会在节目简介中链接它。那一集是和可爱的杰斯一起录制的。我想我是一个相当不错的看人专家，
and I love sharing tips and tricks with people, which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficiently. This episode is supported by by write-up and they're a brand I've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years. I really do genuinely rate them and use the write-up platform for each and every clinic session I book or conduct. That's why I'm so happy to be working with them. In case you don't know already, write-up is an all-in-one practice management platform built in the UK for UK clinicians.
并且我喜欢与人们分享那些真正能帮助他们更高效地开展临床实践的技巧和窍门。本集节目得到了Write-up的支持，这是一个我在自己的临床实践中使用了六年多的品牌。我真的由衷地评价他们，并在我预定或进行的每一个诊所会话中使用Write-up平台。这就是为什么我这么高兴能与他们合作。如果你还不知道的话，Write-up是一个一体化的诊所管理平台，由英国本土为英国临床医生打造。
So that's your diary, your client records, your notes, your invoicing, your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant, all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap-to-pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with, the system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com.
所以这就是你的日程本、你的客户记录、你的笔记、你的开票、你的安全消息传递，全部在一个地方，全部符合GDPR标准，全部围绕我们实际执业的方式设计。还有，最新消息：他们最近推出了一个AI速记员，可以为你起草会话记录，还有一个“轻触即付”应用程序，可以将你的智能手机变成读卡器。这两者都是那种能静悄悄地每周为你省下好几个小时的小改变。但如果你不想使用所有这些功能也没关系，你大可不必。如果你一直想整理你的管理工作，或者一直在和一个不是为你量身定制的系统苦苦斗争，请看一看 writeup.com。也就是 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。
And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users. What's not to like? Now on with the show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你使用我的代码 Marianne 30 时，你可以获得一个免费的 30 天试用期，最多可供六个用户使用，并享受六个月的 7 折优惠。有什么理由不拒绝呢？现在继续我们的节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。